hello
yes this is he him me right the first
time he'll be right there Mitchell that
was it that was the call I'm going in
due to budget cuts my position as Middle
School music teacher has been eliminated
so I've been working as a high school
sub kaching I never know when I'll be
summoned to swoop into action I'm kind
of like Batman but except for a bat
signal I get a phone call yeah you found
the one difference
I did my best to cram for my lecture on
the Revolutionary War but ugh
all those names and dates it's also dry
where's the drama
good moral
well what is all this strange Garb you
Adorn
are you Trappers from the Canadian
provinces are you here to sell your
beavers
who are you the 64 pins question
I crossed the Delaware during the
Revolutionary War
I spent a brutal winner in Valley Forge
who am I
I I have no idea I I swear I don't know
who this man is I'm George Washington of
course our syllabus says we're supposed
to cover Native Americans on the ebook
colonization yes Native Americans
Indians a majestic peaceful people who
lived off the land and cried when they
saw litter the textbooks as many tribes
were often at war with allegiances
shifting all of this shifting all the
time
so were the Indians friends with the
colonists or not ah yes I know one
Indian who was friends with a
construction worker biker and traffic
cop
nothing seriously nothing okay your
parents are gonna love that joke
Americans in the settlers had two
complete different ideas of land
ownership eventually these differences
would lead to war
oh look Goosebumps
okay yes uh class dismissed
did it thank you so much for stepping in
oh and I promise tomorrow I will do my
best to be more prepared tomorrow why
won't Mrs Hurley be back
good news is that
this is I know what you'd rather have a
raging alcoholic listen to me I've
worked non-stop to build the perfect
academic record and I'm not going to let
you screw it up now I have an AP test in
160 days and I need to Ace it
can you get me there or not
I can rally like the brave men of the
Alamo you do realize that all the men of
the Alamo died they all died
hi oh hey you're going the wrong way
that's the wrong way no wait I'm sorry
you're right
all right excuse me Principal Brown
yikes and you know most Subs just play a
movie all right do something different
guys listen I I can't be your history
teacher those kids work so hard and they
deserve someone who knows the material
and can Inspire them so
if you say so
hey I was wondering what kind of play
was that you were when was that supposed
to be a slant a freshman coach quit I'm
just a glorified babysitter
well your receiver needs to learn to run
his routes or the quarterback's never
going to be able to hit him I played in
college oh okay hey Tyler you need to
learn to run your routes what routes
yeah what routes um
oh I'm gonna line up here
take three steps one two three plant
right open left 45 degrees up the field
okay why don't we try it again try it
again Ted put some zip on the ball 18.
hey
hit him
better better good job
Circle back up all right anyway thank
you for the opportunity hey hey how
would you like to take over this team
oh well that's an interesting offer how
much does it pay nothing are you firm on
that yeah but there's a gym teacher
position available it's all yours if you
coach can I wear shorts yeah and you get
a whistle too I always get a whistle
when I wear shorts I humbly accept your
offer I'm a lot boys let's go hustle do
you know what hustle means ten
[Music]
thank you